all right southwest medical is wishing
you all a happy
healthy new year here's how they can
help you stay well in 2021
so let's start talking about how people
can you know
bring in this new year their healthiest
selves
yes absolutely you know especially in
light of the year that we've just
finished our hope is to make sure that
all of our patients in all of our
communities make this the best year yet
and really with paying attention to
their preventative health care
definitely and you know is it safe to go
into the doctor's office because
obviously that was a huge
question on people's minds in 2020 but
it's trickling into 2021 as well
most definitely you know it's important
to point out that even before the
pandemic
doctor's offices were a safe place there
were a lot of protocols and provisions
that were made
and after the pandemic there's so much
that has changed
to increase and heighten our levels of
sanitation as well as protection
of all medical staff as well as all of
our patients
including limiting the number of
visitors in our buildings screening
anyone and everyone who comes to those
buildings mandating masks and
encouraging hand hygiene as well and
what's the best way to
start a healthy new year
that's a great question and i'm so glad
to bring that up because when it's the
start of a new year we're always trying
to think of
what can we do to keep ourselves healthy
make ourselves healthier
and the answer that really lies in
prevention paying attention to
preventative health
meaning paying attention to things
before we start to
look or feel unwell is so important and
that's really the background behind
primary care medicine
so i encourage all patients to connect
with their primary care providers
and discuss their preventative health
care and then next you just have your
annual wellness visit right and that's
how you can continue to keep track of
where you are most definitely the annual
wellness
visit allows you a one-on-one time with
your provider
to discuss all of your health concerns
and questions
but also to look at specific risk
factors and screening that are tailored
to you
your age your race your history and
certainly things that may be found on
your physical exam
tailored to your specific needs to keep
you as healthy as possible
so in addition to the history that we
take there's a lot of different tests
that can be done in the office
things like ekg tests bone density tests
tests that screen for your mental health
or cognitive impairment
as well as things like circulation nerve
conduction
and diabetes now are there people that
are more at risk if they do not stay on
top of their health care routines
absolutely well prevention is there for
everybody it is important to recognize
that our patients 65
and older might be at higher risk
especially those patients who might have
chronic conditions
such as diabetes as an example 34
million people in the united states have
diabetes
there's other chronic conditions such as
heart disease cancer
and lung disease and it's estimated from
the cdc that six out of
every ten adults in the united states
have at least one chronic care condition
and at least four out of ten have two or
more that's a lot of people that we're
talking about and it's so important for
those individuals to stay up to date
on their chronic care as well as for
their preventative care
and that's also why health screenings
exist right
absolutely screenings are there to help
us look for things
before they have a chance to make us
look or feel
unwell southwest medical has locations
across southern nevada call that number
right there on your screen or just visit
smalv.com for more information